Fox News has again played host to more weaponized
disinformation.
This time, it's coming from Fox News contributor
Bill Bennett.
He's a conservative who's been around a very
long time.
And Bennett trotted out some of the same tired,
boring talking points that just titillate
the Fox News audience, including this is like
a flu.
And this is not a pandemic.
Let's look at the video straight away.
Then we'll break it down.
Bill, what are we missing about this virus?
We see the numbers.
Twenty two thousand dead.
How many cases?
But you took a step back and what did you
find?
Let's take a step back.
The estimates now from numerously wash in,
which was the model everybody has been going
on, even though it's been wrong.
Most of the time, by a lot overstating, it
is now they say 60000 people will die.
Sixty one thousand is what we lost to the
flu in 2017 and 2018.
The flu.
Now we all regret the loss of sixty one thousand
people, if that's what it turns out to be.
I'm going to tell you, I think it's going
to be less and salute all those who are working
in the frontlines on this.
The hospital workers, nurses, doctors, etc.
and the generosity of the American people.
But if you look at those numbers and see the
comparable, we're gonna have fewer fatalities
from this than from the flu.
For this, we scared the hell out of the American
people.
We lost 17 million jobs.
We put a major dent in the economy.
We closed down the schools.
You heard Dr. US say we probably didn't have
to do that, shut down the churches and so
on.
You know, this was not and is not a pandemic,
but we do have panic and pandemonium as a
result of the hype of this.
So we can't let him Gish Gallop.
This is a debate tactic where you just throw
out a ton of stuff and it all sounds difficult
to refute.
We've.
Break it down piece by piece first, Bill Bennett
says if 60000 people die, this won't have
been serious.
Remember, if only 60000 die in the first wave.
We're expecting two to three waves.
It will be because we did all of the stuff
he says we didn't have to do.
Already mentioned it earlier.
This is the anti-vax or conundrum.
Without doing anything, the death toll could
have been a million million and a half.
Two million.
We don't know.
Next, measles.
I'm sorry.
Not measles.
He compares it to the flu, not to measles.
He says, you know, thousand are going to die
from the flu.
And sixty thousand are going to die of coronavirus.
And that's related in some way in his mind.
This has nothing to do with the flu in that
the seasonal flu is not a pandemic.
You have to understand the difference between
a pandemic flu like that of 1918 or the seasonal
flu.
You can have a flu that is a pandemic.
But the current seasonal flu is not.
The seasonal flu happens seasonally.
You've got some immunity because of vaccination
and previous exposure.
You have a much smaller death rate.
There are plenty of functioning antivirals
for the seasonal flu.
It doesn't have a huge impact on the public
at large.
It doesn't require an economic shutdown to
prevent it from going logarithmic.
It doesn't overwhelm the medical system.
Now, of course, you can have a pandemic flu.
We had one in 1918.
This year's flu is not a pandemic flu.
SA's COVA two is not seasonal in any strict
sense without mitigation.
It goes logarithmic and to some degree it
has.
We don't have a vaccine.
We don't have partial immunity.
It has a much higher death rate than the seasonal
flu.
We don't have functioning antivirals and it
has overwhelmed medical system.
So in reality, what we have right now is like
a pandemic flu, but not like the seasonal
flu.
If you don't understand the difference between
a pandemic flu and a seasonal flu, you might
fall for this nonsense.
And the really scary thing is that there was
a time when Bill Bennett was taken seriously
and even considered to be a great thinker
by many on the right.
Hard to imagine.
I know this is another one of these, not a
doctor, not a scientist situations, but they
still get to say things on Fox News.
Weaponized scary stuff